[Music]
in a bet Tibetan is this bet defense
submitted by yeah I know yeah we know I
know I know
oh we know I know your head size
difference is so [ __ ] here you can't
even compete with the size of my tell me
what happens a game of Thrones motive oh
they know the back set from the back
what was it again what was it again one
with huh
I've got Julius Caesar did Tom fuels a
man had to embarrass himself at a dog
park after losing a pet what do you do
eat [ __ ] I was gonna say the minute my
cat people though he had a lot of dog
pee on his face did he dress up as a dog
and I run around like dress up as a dog
and then pee out door and [ __ ] and take
a dump on a fire hydrant
we're probably saying way better [ __ ]
than he had actually probably had to
balance on one leg or some [ __ ] as there
are his friends but I just had him on a
leash just like that's crazy guys try to
think of things that doesn't involve him
being a dog oh I know he bends over and
a dog bones him in the back that's I
grew though now that's a dog as a human
no okay so he's embarrassed he's at a
dog park
oh he's naked getting warmer Cena though
he's not get arrested for like women
suit oh you're getting further away
oh he has peanut butter on his dick yeah
I think we all over his body so that the
Lidcombe alaikum yeah that's
embarrassing pretty good because he has
to be a like a speedo that might feel
kind of good that's awesome
until you don't want aggressive dumb
yeah it's always those French bulldogs
man no do you know all the gross slobber
yeah it's so Steven Oh who's 25 years
old from Arlington Texas he came in last
in his fantasy football league and so he
big mistake so what's gonna happen now
he was given the choice of either paying
$250 to the winning person or perform a
humiliating stuff and so the he chose to
do a stunt which was to stand in a
Dallas dog park for ten minutes only in
only a gold speedo not covered in peanut
butter I like that I like the gold
speedo how did he do that without
getting a boner
great question excellent question
well he was embarrassed terrified I'm
not dogs don't make me horny
no but getting licked everywhere does
but by a human tongue yeah oh it still
feels like good no matter what licks I
think Joe is bad well how do you know
the difference someone is keeping track
of all these t-shirts and just sends us
a list how do you know the difference
though between a man's tongue a dog's
tongue a woman's tongue a homeless man's
tongue lizards tongue if you cleave your
eye the lizards tuck you like that
little spin don't looking thing you're a
populist because you're just saying [ __ ]
everyone agrees with all the time thank
you close your [ __ ] eyes and spread
your legs and something I'm not even
gonna tell you what starts licking your
thighs you're telling me you won't get
one okay do you ain't just videos
everybody something's looking like
thighs know what licked me challenged
he's good do that cheeky party I'm
telling you you're gonna have a hard
time no Joe I said Joey Jeff I want to
see a salamander like how are they gonna
get it to lick yeah spread your legs
open blur it out
he's so ticklish it would never happen
that's what I'm saying I'll be like oh
yeah you're tied up like me
Greyjoy yeah you wouldn't you don't even
know what that reference is no no no but
I see him tied up like that and oh my
god there you go that would do it
signal down if you stick like how we're
doing all right so I'm gonna show you
guys the video I thought it would be
more sport embarrassment I guess to
where that the team that he hates the
motto yeah and going to the opposite
side of town like what a Lakers Jersey
in Boston and see what happens he's
gonna get pretty good yeah Raiders
Jersey though wearing a wearing another
team in a Raiders home you know shoes on
either what did that freak you out if
there's a guy the owners only gone Jesus
he's like the pedophile of the dog park
I know you should just stand there
it does wiki bro he has to say I took a
fancy of a wall bunch and then one of
the owner the dog owners took photo went
viral Z club I can't see is covered in
peanut butter I wonder if that's the
trick like if you just want to have a
good relationship with the dog he's
gotta get some peanut butter and jelly
or if you run a lot and you're covered
in sweat dogs love licking a [ __ ] dude
you have to have punishments and fantasy
football league you have to have you had
any dogs always involve themselves in
your sexual life whether you like it or
not I [ __ ] hate
they just stay come as snow smell your
[ __ ] your like get out of here come
in the lick sometimes they rise a little
bit
exactly it's very odd and not cool no
they're called walkers botamo
I got up to stretch like this oh I was
yawning and then Maddie came up and she
smelled my dick embedded she's like oh
fish today
cuz you know like like you're not dogs
they put their nose like we're here
anyway I think she just kind of put the
bug you know what that means
your ass is [ __ ] curious cuz that the
first sniff a lot of people would be low
but you're like let's see what happened
not me she usually she just does that
all that she does that to everyone
she'll just come up and sniff you really
quick but there's the first time where
she know she likes to dig her nose like
way up in your vagina and she'll want to
smell it she'll come up to your foot and
cool and walk away Tiger does that to
you right now family give him a bath in
the shower if I'm standing and he's
standing he just goes cuz it's all weird
Tim that's what see we know kids do his
own wieners weird in here you just like
what the hell don't do that your head
it's 38 don't do that so I've been in
the same fantasy football league for
many years I've been in the same league
for like ten years
damn that's dedication y'all you guys
are you have to be friends or you just
play with other people online no we're
friends well we all we all were all
YouTube people o tubers this is why you
need punishments when Chris was in the
fantasy playoffs I was in a position
where I could not win and my buddy
Richard was playing Chris the next week
if Chris won so I was playing Chris so I
benched my entire [ __ ]
starters all my players to [ __ ] Chris
over who to let Richard ascend into the
into the playoffs and the whole league
went [ __ ] bonkers and I was [ __ ]
cry
I think they're like too like green laid
down Steve benched all focused artists
only he's [ __ ] trolling this
ridiculous and then I had to I had to
supposed to like start look try to start
some more plans but I couldn't at that
point so I basically threw a game so
because we had no punishment for the
league for getting last place you got
away scot-free that's exactly right
they're like my controls when you don't
have punishments yep so now thou they do
not yeah
we're figuring it out yes knocking upon
peanut butter well basically what the
idea right now is that is one of them
like if whoever loses at the very black
place have to go stand in a freeway
overpass with a sign for an hour it says
I suck at fantasy football honk because
I suck at fantasy and you got to just
stand it for an hour all everyone wrong
situation I dig that one or there a lot
of popular one is a lot of people like
to make the loser go to retake the SATs
that is SAT they actually want to take
it it's gotta be like a three or four
hour long nevermind but if you don't
care about the results yeah but you want
to stay there for the entire time like
you if you finish early you can't be
like oh I've done like scan it through
and I'm done not like us stay there for
the full time to play - yeah ejected
SATs and the ACC T's which won the a CT
a CT was like the alternative to the
SATs so it's like a different like point
scale and stuff but like a bunch of East
Coast school they should score you on
survival skills for high school just
gonna put on can you [ __ ] float in a
pool how about that that's pretty good
but they prep you for the SATs so you
get all ready to take the SATs they just
throw you in a [ __ ] bunny it's like
here's a kid with a Rolly backpack and a
feather hat can you kick his ass
yeah if you can't then you gotta go back
to school yeah you like practice your
salesman skills or whatever like him
convince a bomb bomb can you convince a
bomb to buy you a pack of cigarettes
that's good
can you buy alcohol under the age of 18
at a 7-eleven yep with a pretty pissed
off a manager who's looking for the
shitty bait with a babyface C not easy
[Music]